do you guys think women um pick nice
guys or bad boys
oh i feel like um first
first i will say
i think that when they're young under 25
they go for the bad bad boys okay and
then they learn from experience
i'm trying to put it the best yeah yeah
are you talking from experience
no i'm just saying
[Applause]
but yeah i think that's the bad boys
i agree i think bad boys
i would agree but i personally wouldn't
go for a bad boy because i learned from
other people's mistakes
i was going to say that
you said you said you came from a
two-parent home right do you think that
has helped you vet guys better with guys
yeah because you have your dad as like
an example not necessarily because i
speak to my brother i have an older
brother i speak to him about like boy
problems if i ever like him yeah but um
i wouldn't speak to my dad about it
because where i was i was born here and
my dad's from ghana so they have like
traditional ideologies about what a
relationship should consist of and what
it shouldn't you know i mean so it's
just like it's really hard to explain
that to my father now do you know what i
mean so i just how long have your
parents been married um plus
30 years you don't think it's good to
get an opinion of a guy that's been
married 30 plus years on what to look
for i just feel like i haven't had that
connection with my dad so i'd find it a
little bit awkward to have that
conversation with him yeah whereas with
me and my brother i see my brother more
as the paternal figure because we have
such a vast um age gap
so um yeah but you know what i think it
would be good to get advice from people
who have been in relationships for that
long if they are in tune with what is
going on in 2022
and a lot and i think a lot of parents
who have been
um
together for a long time are together
because they're from a different era but
isn't it kind of impossible for
that for those two things to be together
you know it's somewhat mutually
exclusive for them to be together that
long and then also be in tune with
what's going on now because they haven't
been in the data market right now so
yeah exactly
it's it's kind of like i can't be asking
my dad about
advice for what's going on now
when he was dating what 40 years ago
yeah but i think there's just some
wisdom that comes from
and success
like i was actually shocked when i
started asking my dad for like like
dating advice a little bit like he men
are very insightful i think it's good
you talk to your brother too because i
think men just have it they're better at
vetting men than women are a lot of the
time because we can like
i don't know like the red flag
yeah
men know men yeah yeah
men no sorry are you gonna say something
charlie
it was about what you said about um
being in tune with today's dating scene
if you've been married for such a long
time 30 years
i don't think it makes any difference
because the trends are the same
go on
see you ladies admit you'd go for a bad
boy in your early years
i think if i was to ask the elder women
in my family when they were single
before they got married what kind of
member they attracted to before they
settled down they'd probably say the
same thing i can see the trend happening
with
uh like even girls that i've dated
they'll go with a bad boy but most of
the women that i know that have got
children that are single they're all to
bad boy men
and i find that what you are
i wouldn't i wouldn't sound like no i
wouldn't say i'm a bad boy no i wouldn't
say i'm a bad boy sorry continue
no no i know but i would say that i've
got elements of you know being a bit
direct and being very much like this is
what we need to do to get this stuff
done and i don't mind dismissing a
situation or relationship if it's not
working out and it's beneficial
to the progress of my family
right see i don't necessarily need a
woman to walk into my situation and
think she's going to be a mum there's a
difference between what
i think single men want yeah in
relationships versus what single mothers
want from so your mothers want to step
yeah earlier on you you want that guy to
come in and and look after you because
that would be the natural order of
things the man heads your family whether
that be the biological man to your
children or another one the extra man is
what i would call him um you call him
the extra man the extrovert
he's always going to be extra because
he's never going to come first right
he's not the biological dad the kid
knows that the mum knows that
but i find that men especially myself i
speak for myself
i don't expect any woman to walk into my
life and say
i'm i'm expected to be a stepmom and i
make that very clear like i make it very
clear
this is my responsibility
if you want to take part
and it gets to that point
and you meet my child and you want to go
there you can
but it's not an expectation correct and
i think that's where you have the
jadedness that you have from men that
try to avoid single mums
because
there is the expectation whether women
want to want to admit it or not
that they must step up to the mark yeah
and feel the void that the alpha the bad
boy left behind right
but i think also when it comes to men
and avoiding single mums
you know i'm 24 right now i'm taking my
prime physically in terms of my own
potential you know there's still time to
go there but
the way i i look at it is why would i
want to
get um go into a family that's already
somewhat built and have to i have to
fill that role when i can you know find
someone who doesn't have a kid build my
own home and again like you were saying
before you know i have certain rights to
that kid in terms of how i discipline
him how i do certain things what he um
their
their routine whereas when it's not my
child fair enough i can love that kid
but the moment of mum doesn't love me
anymore it's done it's finished you're
right so you're right and you have no
rights to the kids after
so like i've talked to um guys that have
raised a kid for like 10 years or five
years and and they fall in love with the
kid and then it's over and they can't
see the kid anymore
i had to deal with that myself i had to
deal with it i had to it's a double
breakup right so you break up with the
mother and you also break up with the
child and it's like well i've raised you
for this long and now i'm not even
allowed to see like you became my child
do you know what i mean and so it's like
and that's one of the reasons why i tell
men if they do get with women who are
single mothers you need to understand
exactly what you're getting yourself
into you know do you think that the
stepdads should be able to adopt the
kids if they're in the home more than
the actual dad
um no
i would say that might depend on the
child
because of how important is for a man to
be in the home i think
that might be the way to go um because
again you know father's stop children
stop sons from ending up in prison you
know if if
if a child is a scammer a drug dealer or
is involved in any form of deplorable
activity that could land him in prison
it tends to be because the father isn't
there you know if if a daughter ends up
you know in any form of sex work again
it tends to be because
you know the father isn't there and so
if a man is there you know a
stepfather is there and he's he's
stepping up then i i think it makes
sense
for that child to have this ability of
you know be knowing i am adopted by this
man this man is basically my father now
what do you guys
think there's potential risks if you
well it depends on the um status of the
relationship i i would personally be
married to the person
um i wouldn't take any risk because you
never know what their intentions are
you've got a young kid you never know if
they're you know rapists and stuff like
that so that's one that's one aspect of
it but i would
agree with you and say that a paternal
figure in a household is essential in
terms of parenting and
yeah
so i would agree
i also think that the child should have
some say at a certain age um
because if the biological father is
still stepping up to the plate in some
way shape or form then i feel like then
like if the child is old enough they
should have some kind of say because if
they're adopted or not it won't stop the
person being around and if they're of
age they can make that decision to go
and see them if they're even if they're
not adopted
so i think it really depends
situationally
yeah i agree with both of you guys um
the marriage you know if you're married
to the person you are building up your
future with them they're you know
they've been there for the child um i'd
say five six plus years the child's you
know of age where that you know that
they can have a say in the process um i
do think the
adoption um
would be um essential and beneficial for
for the household and an option
that should be um
yeah that could that could happen do you
think the child should the father should
be able to adopt a child
it's a tough question right because i
think of things from both sides so on
one hand um i i don't really want to see
rights taken away from the biological
debt right
which is why i think it's really
important that it starts at 50 50
custody right but if it's a situation
where it's like an every other weekend
type of thing right
and the step dad's in the house more
than the actual dad i mean it kind of
makes sense
because he's going to have a bigger
impact than the actual dad yeah but the
child this is the thing about that the
child always knows who their biological
father is you could raise a child for
years
right
and that child could not know their
actual biological father but they know
you're not it